es hora de hablar de economía aquí en
directo América de France 24 y hoy nos
acompaña Daniela hablando Daniela Buenas
noches bienvenida Gracias María Clara
empecemos con las noticias económicas de
Estados Unidos donde continúa la
discusión por el techo de la deuda algo
que podría poner en aprietos al gobierno
de Pues claro en una discusión que tiene
como telón de fondo la campaña
presidencial del 2024 Pues el presidente
de la cámara de representantes Kevin
mccarthy presentó un proyecto de ley que
permitirá Elevar el techo de la deuda
pública como quiere el gobierno de Joe
biden pero a cambio de un drástico
reporte recorte presupuestal la
iniciativa evitaría esta temida
parálisis del gobierno de Joe biden por
falta de recursos que se daría en el
próximo verano permitiéndole aumentar su
techo de deuda en 1,5 billones de
dólares desde los actuales 31,4 billones
pero lo está condicionando a este
recorte de gastos
elevará responsablemente el límite de
deuda hasta el próximo año y
proporcionará más de 4,5 billones de
dólares en ahorro para el contribuyente
estadounidense ahora Así es como lo
hacemos primero limitamos el gasto del
gobierno nuestro plan devolvería el
gasto discrecional a los niveles
anteriores al año fiscal inflacionario
2022 Y luego limitaría el crecimiento
del gasto al 1%, en el
percent una pelea fiscal bastante de
difícil Daniela le propongo que
cambiemos el tema y pasemos al Salvador
porque el fondo monetario internacional
hizo una denuncia En qué consiste
específicamente la entidad multilateral
se queja de que las autoridades de este
país centroamericano No han dado
consentimiento para la publicación de su
más reciente informe sobre la economía
ni tampoco del comunicado de prensa
correspondiente Y es que una misión del
fondo monetario visitó el país a finales
de febrero y en ese momento publicó un
informe preliminar en el que sí elogió
el crecimiento Sólido del producto
interno bruto y de las remesas pero
también
disgusto al gobierno del Salvador por su
opinión sobre el bitcoin como moneda de
curso legal en este informe dijo que el
riesgo de inestabilidad financiera
persistía y urgió a que hubiera una
mayor transparencia sobre las
transacciones del gobierno en bitcoins
cuyo uso sigue siendo limitado en el
país usted mencionó que la economía del
Salvador digamos ha ido mejorando algo
totalmente opuesto a lo que pasa en
Argentina donde la inflación ha llegado
a un punto tan alto que comenzaron a
importar billetes comenzaron a importar
billetes O al menos así lo van a hacer
en los próximos semanas porque la casa
de la moneda que es la sociedad Estatal
encargada de imprimir papel moneda y
también otros documentos públicos
anunció que va a tener que traerlos
desde París y Malta que usan proveedores
subcontratados en España y en China para
su fabricación también los van a traer
de Brasil específicamente va a importar
billetes de mil pesos argentinos que son
los de mayor denominación actualmente
debido a que la planta de impresión no
tiene suficiente papel moneda para
cubrir la demanda todo como lo decía a
causa de una inflación que ya llega al
ciento cuatro por ciento anual parte del
problema Cuál es que ese billete
equivalía en 2017 cuando fue lanzado a
un poco más de 57 Dólares pero
actualmente solamente representa unos
cuatro un poco más de 4 dólares al
cambio oficial y dos dólares en el
mercado paralelo la devaluación ha sido
tal que A mediados de este año va a
entrar en circulación un nuevo billete
con denominación de 2.000 pesos con las
consecuencias que eso tiene también para
la gente que ve reducida su capacidad de
compra Daniela y cuáles son los
indicadores de este miércoles Wall
Street de cerro mixto después de que la
reserva Federal en su informe periódico
conocido como el libro beige alertará
sobre una disminución de los créditos la
Fed dice que los bancos en Estados
Unidos han endurecido los requisitos
para conceder préstamos en medio de la
incertidumbre y también de la falta de
liquidez en Europa las bolsas cerraron
con mínimas variaciones París subió
levemente allí particularmente el
mercado está expectante por las
inspecciones que Está realizando la
autoridad de competencia a las firmas de
moda y es que ya se conoció que la
empresa de lujo italiano Gucci figura
dentro de esta investigación por
posibles prácticas restrictivas y en
América Latina la bolsa de Sao Paulo
retrocedió al igual que la de Buenos
Aires en Argentina El dólar está en el
mercado informal registrando nuevos
récords ya se cotiza en 423 pesos bueno
llegamos a mi parte favorita de economía
Daniela la cifra qué número nos tiene
hoy el número de hoy tiene que ver con
tesla 2500 millones de dólares son las
ganancias de este carro de este carro no
de esta empresa de vehículos eléctricos
en el primer trimestre del año El
fabricante decepcionó al mercado con una
caída del 24% frente al primer trimestre
del año pasado y este año ha liderado
una campaña de reducción de precios por
si le interesa comprar han venido
reduciendo los precios para estimular
esa demanda afectada por los vientos de
recesión y de hecho también por si le
interesa su presidente elon musk dice
que cree que este mismo año va a lanzar
su muy esperado sistema de conducción
totalmente automático bueno se nota que
usted tiene ganas de un carro tesla pero
me da miedo que me lo conduzca otra
persona
Gracias por todas las noticias
económicas nos vemos mañana
[Música]